(hollering)
- Dinner!
- My name is Tony Peacock.
- Robby Goodman.
- My name is Sheila
Frye, I am a ten time--
- Six time--
- Two time champ of the
National Hollerin' Contest
of Spivey's Corner North Carolina.
- Hollerin' is a controlled sound
that farmers used to communicate
with one another before
they had modern conveniences
like electricity or telephones.
(hollering)
Hollerers had a certain rhythm,
and a modulation that would create an echo
that would travel over a long distance.
(hollering)
But there isn't just one type of holler.
- There are actually
four types of hollers.
Number one: functional—
it serves a purpose.
(hollering)
Such as calling down to a field,
or calling up from a field
when you needed something.
Number two: communicative.
(hollering)
You're communicating a message,
such as good morning, good evening.
Number three: distress.
(hollering)
You need help.
Number four: expressive—
just for sheer fun.
(hollering)
Many times that could be in
the form of tunes or ditties.
(hollering)
These types of hollers were
what the judges were looking for
at the National Hollerin' Contest.
- The first ever National
Hollerin' Contest was in 1969.
It was started to raise funds for
the local fire department,
it became a nationwide hit.
Hey, that's me, I won the
junior division in 1978,
my holler was a distress holler,
and it sounded like a siren.
- And I'm proud to be a winner.
- Everybody had their own
twist that they put on it.
The National Hollerin' Contest ran
for about 48 years till 2015.
We created the World
Wide Hollerin' Festival
that's located in Hope
Mills to try to preserve
and keep the tradition of hollerin’ alive.
- Hollerin' is an important
piece of culture in this region
because it helps us remember our past.
We can also appreciate the
modern conveniences we have today.
- Hollerin' is part of simpler times,
and it's just something
that we need to treasure
because we need to know our history.
- I love hollering cause it
brings the community together,
and just the fellowship that
you have with one another.
We want to keep that tradition alive.
(soft music)
(ping)